c'est à la télévision s'introduit dans
la vie privée elle va s'introduire aussi
un jour dans la vie publique
ainsi les jukebox ces merveilleuses
machines distributrices de musique et
bien le distribueront un jour de la
musique et des images dans les cafés ça
c'est sûr et un jour viendra où on
glissera une pièce dans une forme de
monnaie et on n'aura qu'à choisir en
appuyant sur les boutons en appuyant sur
les petits boutons vous aurez aussi
facilement gloria lasso et pablo casals
il n'y aura qu'à appuyer sur les boutons
bien bien madeleine lui en mains nues de
m
un mouvement admirable s'étendre mais 3
qui prend le meilleur sur buffalo
collection est une indiscutable réussite
est d'ailleurs la robe d'organdi que pas
plus que de mal dans les 18 mètres le
terrain est très sec le temps est
magnifique
ouah
et vous entrerez dans un café ainsi moi
par exemple dans ce café je suis dans
vingt ans par exemple dans ce café j'ai
envie d'entendre un ami guy béart qui
chantent
l'eau vive